All right, welcome back, everybody. We are back.
It's April, we're back from vacation. And I think
it's important now that we're back from vacation
for a few days before our next six month vacation.
That's a joke, by the way. We're really back. We
actually are back to talk about something that's
sort of splitting the audience. The audience is,
in a sense, divided about coverage of the former
president, Donald Trump. The talking about the
former president Donald Trump since the end of
his presidency is now several months in history.
I am here to tell you that for shows like ours,
it would be irresponsible not to cover
Donald Trump in a very specific sense. Now,
we cover many different things on this program.
We cover world politics and science, the pandemic
and medical research technology, interviews
with cultural and psycho psychology experts,
sociology, so many different things. But
fundamentally, we cover American politics.
And there are two main parties in the United
States, like it or not, and I don't like it.
Those two parties are Democrats
and Republicans. And for now,
most Republicans support Donald Trump. 75 million
of them voted for Donald Trump just months ago.
Donald Trump's presence in American politics,
his role over the next two years will determine.
The future of the Republican Party, how do I do a
show about American politics and not cover Trump?
There is a case to be made and I've made it myself
that with Trump gone, his statements need not be
regarded with any particular respect or deference
merely because he's the former guy. 99 percent of
what Donald Trump said while president made no
sense, his instincts were uniformly terrible.
He mismanaged just about everything that he
got involved in. So there's no doubt whatsoever
about that piece. We see him as a failed former
president. Trump is a former president and
he's also, in a sense, a guy who got just about
everything wrong. But. To do what some want done,
which is to ignore Trump, pretend he never
happened, pretend he has no more role to play
in American politics, when the Republican Party
still mostly defers to him and Republican voters
still mostly support him would be silly and it
would sort of be pretending to live in a world
that's different from the one we actually
live in. We don't do that with flat earths.
We don't do that with native AXA's. So we can't
pretend that Donald Trump is now irrelevant.
It's also important to cover the continued
scandals because it needs to continually be used
to put pressure on the Republicans who still
defend Donald Trump later in today's show as
an example. I'm going to tell you about a massive
Trump fundraising scam which has just been exposed
that has completely blown up in Donald
Trump's face and in the faces of Republicans.
They were surreptitiously charging people's
credit cards almost like a subscription,
which you might expect with a cable bill or a cell
phone bill, but not with a political donation.
It's outrageous. It has to be exposed. It has to
be known. Trump after. Here's another example.
After railing against council culture right
alongside Republicans for months or years now,
Trump is now demanding boycotts of a list of
nearly a dozen companies, an organization that's
a massive, laughable, cartoonish hypocrisy where
the Republican Party is complicit. And we have
to report that. So, bottom line, I would like for
Trump never to have happened going back to 2015,
2016. Sadly, the Republican electorate and here's
a way in which it's very different than the
Democratic electorate. The Republican electorate
was bamboozled into supporting Donald Trump. Trump
ran as a Democrat. It never would have happened.
And we are where we are today. I would like
for Donald Trump to have no more influence
over American politics. But unfortunately,
Republican voters, that same ignorance that
led them to fall for Trump five years ago
has led them to continue supporting Donald Trump
today for the most part. So the reality I wish
to be true, the reality most of you wish to
be true, which is that Trump never happened.
It's not reality. And to pretend it is as some
kind of protest by pretending Trump is saying
nothing and doing nothing and wielding no power
at all, particularly when he's slowly inching and
crawling his way back into politics. Now that it's
been a few months since he officially left office,
that would be irresponsible. So we can't
do that. I think the the goal should be
to couch everything that Donald Trump is doing
in the context of what does this mean for the
future of the Republican Party? Is this a
party that is saying that was a mistake and
we have to distance from it? So far they are
not. And that's arguably the biggest story
right now. So that's my perspective at this
point in time. I know different shows are
taking different approaches, but for me, I can't
pretend things are different than what they are.
And right now, the Republican Party is still
heavily a pro Trump party and one in which,
until another leader comes forward, is
still essentially deferring to Donald Trump
on most issues. And we're going to look at
some examples of that later today. But first,
let's talk about this incredible, incredible
fundraising scam that has completely collapsed.